mm rest - Rihanna back today we're going
to play some slender tablets with the
oculus rift uh to start the game
hi so I'm a big fat Slendy I'm a big [ __ ]
Teletubby character [ __ ] care like a
[ __ ]
I like her even though I move my
flashlight it stays the same place
anyway
hahaha so surprisingly enough this is
the one that works the best with the
oculus like looking down at my body and
all that [ __ ] the other ones were pretty
[ __ ] terrible this one is the one
making me least motion sick as well and
if you get motion sickness it's more
like watch def what tree what are you
doing
what are you doing here tree can I jump
or alright here we go here we go this is
what I wanted
how do I pick oh no oh no oh no this is
actually staring with a [ __ ] oculus
it's not fair it's gonna be fine
this is stupid Nara game stupid stupid
re game I'm collecting my parties and
I'm a party with my brows my parties my
slanty parties I don't know what you're
just blurry feet done what what what
just happened
okay well that's cool hey Trey how you
doing man I have another party putea
I'll take you thank you very much oh no
oh no no no what did I do
whose job bloody hell of it done don't
chase me bro don't chase me bro
don't chase me bro rah ha ha ha what do
you want
he doesn't even have a running animation
I love it it's actually scary I can't
explain it okay I can't actually it's
scary that's there you go that's a bit
of okay is he still I think we chased
that little [ __ ] I think we got him
right where we want him and your mama's
ass
that was very rude I'm sorry hope your
mom wasn't watching this I'll edit that
out pits
sorry mom's what what what s going on
where's my patty put ice aperto pootie
it's my pate Polly now not [ __ ] not yet
I shut they're on to me Oh job naughty
cute cannibal farm Yanis odd you piece
of [ __ ]
well at least there's only one usually
there's two of those [ __ ] I don't
like when there's two [ __ ] one [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ]
it's like minus minus becomes plus
actually doesn't make sense alright the
[ __ ] go I'd [ __ ] Slendy [ __ ] I
know there's like a cave or something
that you can go to man I'm fast
oh [ __ ] oh there's the hill isn't this
the hill it is to hell all hail the
mighty Sun tell it abyss tell it abyss -
oh oh oh I'm inside my god blood wasn't
on dean tequila
oh your blood wasn't wrong did you know
I I just got inside you seriously what
is happening I just find this awesome
place and what are you doing calmed it
down
why are you dead stupid [ __ ] god
dammit I hurt my hand by the way why are
they burning it was jump look I'm
suddenly free pawn look nany area what
that what are you what hi were you
worried who are you [ __ ] me huh
you're me do anything
map calibrating what are you that you
don't even do anything
you're a picture you want to be friends
is that it come here let me kiss you
well that was a piece of [ __ ] what not
again
thanks for scaring me appreciate it ah
I'm dare you Edgar
hope you boys enjoyed this episode if
you did go ahead and leave a like I
really appreciate all the support hit
subscribe home abroad today in that pull
and I've got it will scatter you in your
nightmares but I'll feel oh why am I not
getting enough points ow
there's one sound no no
for deaf foxy